تظاهرات اليوم في فرنسا والتي تحولت الى
مواجهات مع الشرطه تعد استمرارا للضغط على
حكومه ماكرون التراجع عن خطتها لاصلاح
نظام التقاعد المثيري للجدل هذه التظاهرات
هي سابع تحرك احتجاجي لاختبار استمرار
المواجهه بين الحكومه والنقابات لتراجع عن
رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما
ويعتبر الفرنسيون التعديلات غير عادله
خصوصا بالنسبه للنساء والعاملين في
الوظائف الشاقه
التحركات الاحتجاجيه سجلت رقما قياسيا
الاسبوع الماضي حيث وصلت الى اكثر من
ثلاثه ملايين متظاهر بحسب النقابات
الفرنسيه
وكان مشروع القانون قد خطا خطواته الاولى
نحو الاقرار حينما اقر مجلس الشيوخ الماده
السابعه والاصلاح التي ترفع سن التقاعد
سنتين الاسبوع الماضي وقد دافع الرئيس
ماكرون عن القانون وقال في رساله للاتحاد
ان رفع سن التقاعد النقابي في الحكومه ان
الحكومه ستبقى مستمعه بهذا الشان معتبرا
ان هذا القانون ضروري ومع اصرار مكروه على
المضي قدما في اقرار القانون فهو يراهن
بجزء كبير من رصيده السياسي ما قد يؤثر
سلبا على ولايته الثانيه وتقول الحكومه ان
رفع سن التقاعد القانوني هو ضروري
استجابه للتدهور المالي الذي تشهده صناديق
التقاعد
ولشيخوخه السكان في فرنسا